[Music]
here's a philosophical question for you
if a color doesn't have a name can we
still see it well many years ago the
human eye evolved to give us the ability
to see about a million colors that's a
lot then how come until very recently
nobody saw or even heard of the color
blue well it's because blue just didn't
exist yet
let's find out why
[Music]
blue is a mysterious color
to people of the ancient world like the
greeks blue wasn't a color at all this
weird story starts with william
gladstone a four-time prime minister of
great britain and uh he was a huge fan
of homer
[Music]
not that homer uh greek homer
homer wrote the iliad and the odyssey
and these two epic poems are considered
the foundation of all ancient greek
literature and much of modern literature
is in some ways derivative of homer so
gladstone was reading the odyssey and
noticed homer described the wine dark
sea not blue not green wine dark and
this description got gladstone
interested in other ways homer used
color to describe things homer describes
honey as being green and sheep as being
violet colored glad still wondered if
homer was colorblind and saw blue as
maybe something else so he went through
thousands of pages of homer's writing
and counted his references to color
black is mentioned almost 200 times
white about a hundred times red is
mentioned 13 times yellow and green
fewer than 10 times but blue
zero so gladstone looked through other
ancient greek writing nothing was ever
described as being blue gladstone's
initial thought was maybe the greeks saw
color differently than other people so
researchers analyzed ancient texts from
all over the world the quran the hebrew
bible ancient chinese hindu icelandic no
blue not once these ancient texts
reference colors with pretty much the
same proportion as homer's epics black
and white appear a lot red a few times
yellow and green appear very little but
blue never appears at all and human eyes
are the same now as they were back then
so why couldn't they see blue simple is
it everything was in black and white no
that's not accurate
i've seen the movies
all languages evolve in their own way
but almost universally names for colors
emerge in the same order first a
language creates the words for black and
white the next color is always red after
red it's either yellow or green the last
color to appear in every major language
is blue and this makes sense if you
think about it how often does blue
appear in nature we see black and white
everywhere blood is red so humans are
familiar with that color but what in
nature is blue only 10 of flowers are
blue so pretty rare but even more rare
in animals birds mammals reptiles none
of them produce blue pigment yes there
are a couple of blue butterflies but
that's not pigment they're actually
brown the color blue is created because
of the way their wings are structured at
the microscopic level same with blue
feathers of peacocks or blue jays blue
toads even people with blue eyes that
blue isn't pigment it's the microscopic
structure of the eye or the feathers or
the skin that scatters the light in a
way that appears blue and since blue is
so rare in nature most ancient cultures
didn't see blue as a separate color but
rather a shade of green languages are
efficient why bother making up a word
that you'll hardly ever need the ocean
wasn't blue it was a shade of green the
sky wasn't blue it was light black blue
finally emerges as its own color when
the egyptians invented a way to produce
a blue dye suddenly the light black sky
was blue the nile river green for
thousands of years finally became blue
as egyptian blue dye made its way around
the ancient world languages evolved to
accommodate this new color but before
that nothing so unless you have a word
to describe a color it becomes really
difficult for humans to perceive it and
there's proof of this even today
[Music]
researcher jules davidoff conducted an
experiment with the himba tribe in
africa and like ancient cultures the
himba have no word for blue to the himba
blue is just a shade of green so himba
participants were shown 12 squares on a
screen 11 of the squares were green one
was blue can you pick out the blue
square now of course you can you found
it immediately but the himba had trouble
with this color they had a lower
reaction time than you or i would but
quick side note you'll see lots of
reports about this study that say the
himba couldn't see the blue square at
all that's not true the bbc and business
insider made that part up it's a
complete fabrication oh wait a minute i
thought the media follows the science
well so the media only follows science
if it fits their story uh it would seem
so well you can knock me over with the
feather anyway what about this diagram
all 12 of these squares are green but
one of them is a slightly different
shade can you pick out which one now go
ahead and pause it if you need more time
[Music]
could you find it
this square is slightly lighter than the
others and most of us can't see any
difference if we study the colors and
try to really focus we might get it but
it's not easy but the himba they saw
this different green as easily as we
found the blue square the himba don't
just have one word for green they have
unique words and whole categories of
words for many shades of green because
of this the himba people are already
primed to recognize them now since they
don't have a word for blue they know
it's different but they can't really
explain why here's another test what
color is this pink right this is easy
because we have a name for this color
but the word pink doesn't appear in
english until about the 13th century
before then
pink was red a lighter shade of red sure
but still just red and if you tell
someone an object is light red without
being more specific that color will be
different for everybody and scientists
have learned that until a word is
created to describe a color people have
a difficult time defining it we now have
mint green forest green kelly green and
i'm sure art students and crayola
junkies can name a bunch more but before
these words existed these colors were
difficult to describe isaac newton
famously discovered the color spectrum
which is what colors
right but where does red end and orange
start what color is indigo is it dark
blue or is it closer to violet isaac
newton himself had trouble separating
the bands he initially thought there
were 11 unique colors but then he
thought maybe just five but a week has
seven days and there are seven tonal
notes in a musical octave and pythagoras
thought seven was a magical number so
newton said effort let's call it seven
colors in modern science we measure
colors in nanometers so we could say
with precision that pure yellow is 580
nanometers but newton didn't use
wavelengths he just eyeballed it uh
that's not very scientific it's not oh
newton would've been a good journalist i
see what you did there so if people
require a color to have a name in order
to quote unquote see it are there
unnamed colors visible to the human eye
that we haven't yet discovered it sounds
crazy but yes there are
human vision is trichromatic this means
we have three different photoreceptors
in our eyes that detect color called
cones we have cones for red green and
blue and every color we see is a
combination of these and this allows us
to see about a million different colors
and people who are colorblind only have
two functioning cone cells which lets
them only see about 10 000 shades this
is diachromatic vision and most mammals
are dichromats but a few years ago a
doctor in northern england was found to
have four types of cone cells so her
vision isn't trichromatic it's
tetrachromatic this means she doesn't
just see a million colors she can
distinguish up to a hundred million
different colors
she's like a superhero with the
supervision well yeah at first
scientists thought this was really rare
but then they started investigating the
phenomenon they found something
interesting in the genetics of
colorblind people colorblind men have
two normal cone cells and one mutant
cone that's less sensitive to either red
or green light but the mothers and
daughters of colorblind men had one
mutant cone in addition to three normal
cones about one in twelve men are
colorblind so about eight percent of
them based on this statistic around 12
percent of the entire female population
should be tetrachromatic with the
ability to see a hundred million colors
a hundred times more than the rest of us
so where are all these women and what
extra 99 million colors do they see
well they don't even know they have
access to these colors just like the
ancient people weren't primed to see
blue as its own color women with
tetrachromatic vision haven't been
primed to see all these new colors so
one tetrachromatic woman was given a
vision test and she was shown a sequence
of colors in rapid succession people
with normal vision see these colors as
identical but this woman was able to see
the subtle differences her brain was
primed to make her aware that some of
the colors she was going to see could be
different and she was able to pick out
these small changes instantly and
accurately so what do these colors look
like to the rest of us well there's no
way to describe it here's a quick
thought experiment how do you describe
color to someone who's been born blind
um okay i got one
orange is like a warm summer's day a
gentle breeze rustles the [__] willows
you can smell the honeysuckle in the
distance the wobble of a meadowlark what
are you doing writing a haiku i was
always being rhetorical oh right yeah
colors are hard to describe
so our ancestors saw colors exactly the
same way we do but they never noticed
differences until words were created to
describe them isaac newton learned that
colors are not part of material objects
color is just the way light is absorbed
reflected and scattered by a surface and
if you think of it that way color
doesn't really exist it's just an
interpretation of a wavelength bolado a
neuroscientist at university college
london said there's such a thing as
light there's such a thing as energy
there's no such thing as color color is
nothing more than the product of light
our culture our language and our own
imagination
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment share
that stuff really helps out a small
channel and until next time be safe be
kind and know that you
are appreciated
[Music]
you